JEFFERY WRIGHT
Reality is not a straight line.
Every passing moment is a chance
for a new offshoot. A new variation.
In fact, there are more realities
than you can possibly fathom.
An infinite number of ‘What Ifs’.
I’m Jeffrey Wright, and as the voice of
The Watcher in Marvel’s What If,
I can see what few others can:
the totality of the multiverse
across all time and space.
The stories you thought you knew
are nothing like you remember.
Familiar faces...
KORATH
Who are you?
JEFFERY WRIGHT
…in unfamiliar roles.
KORATH
Star-Lord!
JEFFERY WRIGHT
A captain…
COLONEL FLYNN
Women aren’t soldiers.
CARTER
Howard, get ready!
HOWARD
Agent Carter!
JEFFERY WRIGHT
…No one expected.
And foes… who became friends.
JEFFERY WRIGHT
Wow, I did not see that coming.